[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe heute Morgen eine Umfrage gemacht
und gefragt: "Ist es euch schon zu spät für Zwetschgenkuchen
oder ist es noch okay?"
Und, ich glaube, 85% oder 90% waren es,
die gesagt haben: "Ja, mach Zwetschgenkuchen."
Also gibt es jetzt heute Zwetschgenkuchen,
Zwetschgendatschi,
einmal ganz traditionell mit Hefeteig vom Blech,
einmal eine schnelle Variante mit Quark-Öl-Teig
und am Ende machen wir eine Verkostung.
Und ihr könnt ja mal schon mal in die Kommentare schreiben:
Mögt ihr Zwetschgenkuchen?
Mögt ihr ihn mit Hefeteig oder Quark-Öl-Teig oder Rührteig
und mit Streusel oder ohne Streusel?
Weil, ich glaube, das ist so die Grundsatzdiskussion immer.
Was sagt ihr?
Josh?
>> JOSH: Mit Streusel.
>> SALLY: Mit Streusel.
Max?
>> MAX: Mit Streusel.
>> SALLY: Aylin?
>> AYLIN: Mit.
>> SALLY: Mit. Okay.
Ich glaube, wir machen später vielleicht so halb/halb
und dann gucken wir mal.
Aber ich bin auch eher so der Fan mit Streusel.
Also jetzt erst mal hier zum Hefeteig für ein ganzes Blech.
Ich nehme dafür
21 Gramm Hefe,
– das ist ein halber Würfel –
einen Esslöffel Wasser,
40 Gramm Zucker,
350 Gramm Mehl,
– da könnt ihr Dinkel oder Weizen nehmen –
etwa 150 bis 180 Gramm Milch,
ein Ei,
etwas Salz
und 40 Gramm weiche Butter.
Was ich später auch machen werde, ist,
ich mache noch einen runden Kuchen.
Also, falls ihr mal weniger Zwetschgen dahabt,
könnt ihr das Ganze natürlich auch in rund machen,
müsst nicht direkt ein ganzes Blech backen.
Und ich werde dann einfach auch
die vegane Version machen.
Denn gerade so einen Hefeteig
kann man echt super vegan zubereiten,
Streusel auch.
Und dann schreibe ich euch da die vegane Version
einfach auch mit auf den Blog
und dann habt ihr das auch.
Und in meiner App könnt ihr auch wirklich alle Zutaten
hoch- und runterrechnen lassen.
Also auch, wenn ich ein Blech angebe,
könnt ihr daraus einen runden Kuchen backen
oder eben auch andersrum.
Jetzt hier am besten zuerst die Hefe
mit Wasser und Zucker vermischen.
[Musik]
Die Milch mache ich jetzt gerade noch kurz warm,
nur, dass die so ein bisschen lauwarm ist.
Das ist besser für den Hefeteig,
dass die eben nicht aus dem Kühlschrank kommt.
Das reicht schon.
Und jetzt gebt ihr einfach alle Zutaten hier rein,
direkt das ganze Mehl,
ein Ei,
Salz
und Milch.
Bei der Milch bin ich immer erst mal ein bisschen vorsichtig,
gebe ein bisschen weniger dazu.
Und Butter und Salz einfach immer ganz zum Schluss,
damit die nicht direkt mit der Hefe in Verbindung kommen.
Und jetzt könnt ihr den Teig einfach
zu einem richtig schönen geschmeidigen Teig kneten.
[Musik]
Und auskratzen.
So sieht der Teig perfekt aus,
lässt sich gut lösen,
ist schön weich, aber auch nicht zu weich.
Also ich habe ein bisschen Milch tatsächlich noch übrig.
Jetzt fette ich meine Hände so ein bisschen,
– die tanzt halt –
forme das Ganze jetzt zu einer schönen Kugel.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier auch die Schüssel so ein bisschen fetten,
die Kugel reinlegen,
die Oberfläche fetten, damit es nicht austrocknet,
und dann den Teig abgedeckt
für etwa eine Stunde aufgehen lassen,
bis er sich verdoppelt hat.
Falls ihr die Gärstufe am Backofen habt,
also einen Dampfbackofen,
könnt ihr den auch dort bei 34°C mit Dampf aufgehen lassen.
Da halbiert sich die Aufgehzeit
und der Teig wird einfach schön luftig
und trocknet eben an der Oberfläche nicht aus.
Das mache ich eben mal schnell.
[Musik]
Also den runden Kuchen mache ich jetzt vegan.
Da habe ich jetzt hier schon
Hefe, Zucker und Wasser vermischt.
Da gebe ich die Zutaten auch direkt in die Schüssel
und statt Butter nehme ich vegane Butter
und statt normaler Milch nehme ich einfach Hafermilch
oder eben eine andere pflanzliche Milch.
Und das war es dann im Prinzip schon.
[Musik]
So ein süßer kleiner Teig!
Das Backtrennspray, das ist auch vegan.
Das ist nämlich nur Kokosfett und Rapsöl.
Und den lasse ich jetzt auch schön aufgehen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit für den Blechkuchen
einfach schon mal die Streusel zubereiten.
Denn wir machen ja halb/halb,
mit Streusel und ohne Streusel.
Für die Streusel nehme ich
90 Gramm Butter,
90 Gramm Zucker,
einen viertel Teelöffel Salz,
180 Gramm Mehl
– da könnt ihr auch Weizen oder Dinkel nehmen –
und zum Verfeinern einen Teelöffel Zimt.
Und auch hier bei der veganen Version
einfach vegane Butter verwenden
und dann habt ihr schon vegane Crumble.
Ich gebe jetzt hier alle Zutaten in die Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt aber auch alles
mit einem Teigzerhacker so ein bisschen zerhacken
oder kurz die Finger benutzen.
Geht beides wunderbar.
Salz ist übrigens immer superwichtig!
Wenn ihr Vanillestreusel machen wollt,
einfach Vanilleextrakt,
wenn ihr Tonka-Streusel machen wollt,
einfach Tonkabohne mit rein.
Also die könnt ihr auch echt super verfeinern.
Und jetzt kurz vermischen.
[Musik]
Da war die Butter wohl noch zu kalt.
Die darf ruhig ein bisschen weich sein.
Ich lasse sie jetzt einfach länger rühren.
>> JOSH: Dann gibt es nicht so eine Sauerei.
>> SALLY: Dann macht es auch nicht so eine Sauerei.
[Musik]
So sehen die Streusel jetzt perfekt aus,
also so schöne grobe Streusel.
Falls sie zu fein sind,
– ich hatte eben auch das Problem,
war einfach, weil die Butter noch zu kalt war –
dann gebt den Streuseln einfach so ein bisschen Handwärme.
So ein bisschen zusammendrücken
und dann
entstehen sie so.
Die kann ich jetzt kurz kaltstellen,
bis der Hefekuchen so weit ist,
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
– wenn ihr nämlich die Quark-Öl-Version macht,
dann macht ihr die Streusel auch zuallererst,
weil die eben schneller fertig sind.
Dann könnt ihr den Quark-Öl-Teig direkt danach machen.
Und das mache ich jetzt.
Denn meine Zwetschgen sind schon entsteint und halbiert.
Für den Quark-Öl-Teig verwende ich
300 Gramm Quark,
– das ist ein Magerquark –
zwei Eier,
etwa 100 Gramm Milch,
80 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl oder Rapsöl,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Mehl,
ein Päckchen Backpulver,
100 Gramm Zucker
und etwas Salz.
Was ich am Quark-Öl-Teig so schätze, ist,
dass er wirklich supereinfach ist,
man hat keine Aufgehzeit
und ich finde den einfach lecker und locker.
Also immer, wenn ich mal Lust
auf einen schnellen Kuchen habe
oder allgemein auf Kuchen,
ist Quark-Öl-Teig eigentlich schon so
die beste Variante, muss ich sagen.
Obwohl ich ein sehr, sehr großer Hefeteigfan bin,
muss ich das echt zugeben.
Und gerade bei so Obstkuchen
ist schon Quark-Öl-Teig so der Favorit.
Also...
Ja.
Und ich habe halt auch immer alle Zutaten da,
also Eier, Öl und Quark,
die trockenen sowieso.
Von daher kann ich den halt auch immer zubereiten.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier
– ihr seht schon –
alles in eine Schüssel.
Das ist so ein All-in-Teig.
Das heißt, alles rein und dann auf einmal verrühren.
Ja.
Dann das Mehl.
Da könnt ihr jetzt auch Dinkel oder Weizen nehmen.
Backpulver.
Zucker und Salz.
Es war andersrum.
Das war Salz
und das war Zucker.
Wäre sonst ein bisschen herzhaft.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr hier noch Zitronenabrieb reingeben
oder Zimt oder Tonkabohne.
Also auch wieder verfeinern, wie ihr möchtet.
Oder in Schokoversion dann einfach mit dem Kakaopulver.
Jetzt kurz verrühren
in der Hoffnung, dass nichts rausspritzt.
[Musik]
Mh, noch ein bisschen,
ein kleines bisschen.
[Musik]
Zack, schon fertig.
Nicht mal eine Minute verrührt.
Also wirklich nur so weit rühren,
dass sich alles gut verbunden hat.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier meinen Backrahmen.
Den kann ich jetzt direkt auf Blechgröße ausziehen.
Ich habe hier das Lochblech drunter und eine Dauerbackfolie.
Dann kommt der Teig direkt rein.
[Musik]
Kurz verstreichen.
Den Ofen habe ich jetzt auch schon vorgeheizt.
Das ist jetzt natürlich auch wichtig,
gerade bei dem Kuchen,
weil ich jetzt hier mit Backpulver arbeite,
dass der eben jetzt nicht rumsteht,
sondern direkt in den warmen Ofen kommt.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier meine Zwetschgen.
Die sind, wie gesagt, bereits entsteint und halbiert.
Und je nach Größe könnt ihr sie halbieren oder vierteln.
Und hier jetzt einfach schön im Blech verteilen.
[Musik]
Und da nimmt man halt auch Zwetschgen
und keine Pflaumen, weil die einfach backstabiler sind
und Pflaumen zu wässrig sind.
Und die würden den Kuchen halt total verwässern,
obwohl ich, muss ich sagen,
Pflaumen so optisch schöner finde.
Aber zum Backen sind die halt besser.
[Musik]
Das sieht schon sehr gut aus!
Und wie gesagt, mache ich jetzt die Hälfte mit Streuseln
und die Hälfte ohne Streusel.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was besser ankommt.
Und auf die Hälfte ohne Streusel
streue ich jetzt einfach noch Mandelblättchen.
So irgendwas Knackiges, finde ich, muss schon dazu,
entweder Streusel oder eben Mandeln,
dass man so ein bisschen einfach Konsistenzen drin hat,
luftiger Teig,
fruchtige Zwetschgen
und dann so ein Knack.
So.
Und der Kuchen kann jetzt direkt in den Backofen.
Also mit Quark-Öl-Teig ist wirklich
der Kuchen innerhalb von 20 Minuten fertig
und dann im Backofen.
[Musik]
Während der Quark-Öl-Kuchen fast schon fertig ist,
kann ich jetzt hier
mit dem Hefeteig weitermachen.
Also es ist schon so eine Zeitsache, muss man echt sagen.
Aber am Ende, finde ich, zählt dann doch der Geschmack.
Deswegen werden wir gucken, was uns am besten gefällt.
Also auch den Hefeteig werde ich jetzt hier
direkt auf ein Blech geben,
hier einfach mit den Händen so ein bisschen öffnen.
Falls es kleben sollte, entweder die Hände fetten
oder ein bisschen Mehl benutzen.
[Musik]
Schön sieht es aus!
Jetzt hier auch wieder die Zwetschgen drüber verteilen.
[Musik]
So.
Den lasse ich jetzt wieder abgedeckt
eine halbe Stunde ruhen,
werde aber schon mal die Hälfte mit den Mandeln bestreuen.
Denn auch hier machen wir wieder
halb Streusel, halb Mandeln.
Die Streusel gebe ich aber dann
erst nach dem Aufgehen dazu.
Denn ich werde es ja noch mal im Ofen aufgehen lassen
bei Gärstufe und ich will jetzt nicht,
dass die Streusel warm werden.
Also eine halbe Stunde kurz warten
und danach direkt im heißen Ofen backen.
[Musik]
Jetzt
>> MAX: gibt's
>> JOSH: Zwetschgen-
>> SARAH: datschi!
>> SALLY: Juhu!
>> SARAH: Kuchen!
>> SALLY: Wir probieren Kuchen!
>> SALLY: Kuchendatschi.
>> JOSH: Kuchen?
Habe ich Kuchen gehört?
>> SALLY: Also wir haben hier
>> SARAH: Vier Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Nummer eins:
Zwetschgenkuchen vom Blech mit Hefeteig.
Nummer zwei: Zwetschgenkuchen mit Quark-Öl-Teig.
Nummer drei Zwetschgenkuchen mit Quark-Öl-Teig.
>> JOSH: Vom Blech.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also nee. Achtung!
>> SARAH: Quadratisch. Eckig.
>> SALLY: Der Unterschied ist:
Hier probieren wir Hefekuchen
und Quark-Öl-Kuchen ohne Streusel.
Und hier probieren wir Quark-Öl
und Hefe mit Streusel.
>> JOSH: Ah!
>> SARAH: Aber der ist vegan?
>> SALLY: Der ist vegan, aber es macht eigentlich nichts.
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also da schmeckt man keinen Unterschied.
>> JOSH: Weil der Unterschied war nur vegane Butter, oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und halt kein Ei.
>> JOSH: Ah ja, und kein Ei. Ja, stimmt.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und eigentlich geht es mir vielmehr drum...
>> SARAH: Okay. Machen wir eine Reihenfolge
oder probiert jeder durch?
>> JOSH: Es probiert einfach jeder und sagt,
ob er es gut findet oder nicht.
>> SARAH: Jeder probiert.
[Musik]
Was war das?
Aha! Wir haben also genug Zwetschgenkuchen,
um es auf den Boden zu legen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aha! Da kommt der Veganer ganz zum...
Aha! Da kommt jetzt noch einer einfach.
Aha!
>> SALLY & JOSH: Aha!
>> SALLY: Wie gut, dass wir noch eine Gabel haben.
Und Vorsicht, auf dem Boden ist Zwetschge.
>> SARAH: Hier ist deiner.
>> SALLY: Also eigentlich geht es...
Ja, stimmt. Deiner ist da.
>> BENNY: Ah!
>> SARAH: Ich habe es ein bisschen
mit süßem Schnee übertrieben.
>> SALLY: Eigentlich geht es mehr um
so Quark-Öl-Teig-und-Hefeteig-Vergleich
und noch Mit-Streusel-ohne-Streusel-Vergleich.
>> JOSH: Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, welcher
– ah, der war vegan.
>> SARAH: Quark-Öl.
>> JOSH: Ja, nee. Nein.
Das sieht man ja am Teig.
Hallo? So langsam...
So langsam weiß ich das ja.
>> SARAH: Mal probieren, oder?
>> JOSH: Ach so, stimmt ja.
>> MAX: Der schmeckt wie bei Oma.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MAX: Der ist richtig gut.
>> SALLY: Das ist gut.
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich muss den Hefeteig probieren.
>> MAX: Ich nehme mal.
>> SALLY: Ja, alle vier.
>> SARAH: Okay, jeder äußert seinen Favoriten, oder?
>> BENNY: Ich habe meinen.
>> SALLY: Benny hat einen.
>> JOSH: Ja, gut, das...
>> SARAH: War nicht schwer.
>> JOSH: Du bröselst hier ganz schön rum, gell?
Man sieht, wo du gestanden bist.
Darf ich den veganen mal probieren?
>> SALLY: Dürfen wir ein Stück von...
>> BENNY: Na gut.
>> SARAH: Wir müssen alles
>> BENNY: Nur, weil ihr es seid.
>> SARAH: alles vergleichen.
>> MAX: Kann ich das nehmen oder will noch jemand was?
>> SALLY: Da war er weg, der vegane.
>> BENNY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Welches ist dein Favorit?
>> JOSH: Also ich bin auf jeden Fall kein Hefeteigfreund.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich auch nicht.
>> JOSH: Quark-Öl-Teig.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> BENNY: Ach so, das sind unterschiedliche Teige.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> BENNY: Das habe ich jetzt...
>> JOSH: Der Veganer hat es auch mal mitbekommen.
>> BENNY: Ach so.
>> SARAH: Nee, wir haben vier gleiche,
vier gleiche Kuchen.
>> JOSH: Die auch alle unterschiedlich aussehen.
Aber ist halt...
>> BENNY: Es kann ja sein, das eine ist
marokkanische Zwetschge,
das andere ist Waghäuseler Zwetschge.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> BENNY: Kann ja auch sein.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ah!
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> BENNY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Der Feinschmecker.
>> JOSH: Nein.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> SARAH: Falsch gedacht.
>> SALLY: Zu meiner Verteidigung,
warum es nur einen veganen gibt:
Ich wollte noch den Rührkuchen
vegan machen.
>> BENNY: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber ganz ehrlich,
das hätte den Rahmen des Videos gesprengt.
>> BENNY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe schon viel gebacken.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Was ist dein Favorit, Benny!
>> BENNY: Mh.
>> SALLY: Okay, vegan.
Also Hefekuchen mit Streusel.
>> BENNY: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber jetzt so generell,
bist du eher mit Streusel oder ohne?
>> JOSH: Das war doch der Quark-Öl eigentlich.
>> BENNY: Schon mit. Schon mit.
>> SALLY: Mit, nicht?
>> BENNY: Ja, ja, doch.
>> SARAH: Nee, das ist Hefe. Das ist Quark-Öl.
>> SALLY: Deinen, deinen Favoriten kenne ich,
>> SARAH: Hä? Warum?
>> SALLY: glaube ich. Weil das ist auch mein Favorit.
>> JOSH: Die sind beide so flach.
>> SALLY: Was ist den Favorit?
>> SARAH: Oh! Denkst du direkt, wir denken gleich?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MAX: Ich bin normal der Streuseltyp,
aber ich muss sagen, das ist mein Favorit.
>> SALLY: Das? Obstkuchen, also Quark-Öl
>> MAX: Ja.
>> SALLY: ohne Streusel. Okay.
>> JOSH: Quark-Öl mit Streusel.
>> SALLY: Ich bin auch Quark-Öl mit Streusel.
>> SARAH: Ich bin auch Quark-Öl mit Streusel.
>> JOSH: Ich dachte bis eben, das wäre auch Quark-Öl-Teig,
weil das so flach wurde.
>> SARAH: Weil ich bin auch Streuseltyp.
>> SALLY: Ich auch.
>> JOSH: Aber Streusel auf jeden Fall.
>> SARAH: Und du hast jetzt gerade dein Ding gebrochen.
>> MAX: Ja.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Streusel ist so wow.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil das ist ja auch Quark-Öl.
Das ist der gleiche, nur ist halt
– klar, wenn man ihn in der Form backt, rund,
>> JOSH: Ah, krass!
>> SALLY: wird der halt kuchenartiger.
Und so wird er halt so ein bisschen
– habe ich ihn flacher.
>> MAX: Aber das wäre zweiter Platz bei mir.
>> SALLY: Ja, definitiv.
Also Zwetschge hin, Zwetschge her...
>> SARAH: Wir lieben Streuselkuchen sehr.
>> BENNY: Auf jeden Fall.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Macht den Kuchen einfach nach.
Jeden einzelnen nacheinander.
Und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
In der App könnt ihr übrigens
die Rezepte hoch- und runterrechnen,
verdoppeln, verdreifachen, einfrieren.
>> SARAH: Vervierfachen.
>> SALLY: Alles, was ihr wollt.
Vervierfachen.
Und einfach essen.
Und wir werden ihn noch einfrieren.
Dann haben wir noch ganz lange was davon.
>> SARAH: Yes.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und wir werden ihn noch einfrieren.
Dann haben wir noch ganz lange was davon.
>> SARAH: Yes.
>> JOSH: Hä? Wer sagt denn, das da was übrig bleibt?
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> SARAH: Also du nimmst den
>> SALLY: Da haben wir einen schon weg.
>> SARAH: komplett mit.
>> BENNY: Ja, komplett.
>> SARAH: Ich nehme den mit.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Hä?
>> SALLY: Du nimmst den.
>> MAX: Ja, ich nehme den.
>> SARAH: Und das ist halt...
>> JOSH: Ja, okay, ich nehme das Blech.
Komm,
ich opfere mich,
das zu nehmen.
>> SARAH: So.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir so voll den Special Effect machen,
alle unten verschwinden im Keller?
>> SARAH: Ja, okay. Du hast gerade
unseren Trailer nicht gesehen.
>> SALLY: Okay, bei drei.
>> SARAH: Genau so.
>> SALLY: Eins,...
>> BENNY: Warte. Gibt es eine Choreografie?
>> MAX: Warte. Ich muss weiter runter,
nicht dass ich mir den Kopf anhaue.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> BENNY: Was macht ihr jetzt?
>> SARAH: Dong!
>> SALLY: Eins, zwei, drei.
>> MAX: Ach so.
>> BENNY: Wieder hoch?
>> SALLY: Ich komme nicht mehr hoch!
>> MAX: Ach so.
>> SARAH: Hier unten können wir jetzt Kuchen essen.
>> SALLY: Ich hatte ein Workout.
>> SARAH: Ich habe uns Kuchen besorgt.
>> SALLY: Meine Beine tun so weh.
>> MAX: Bleiben wir unten?
>> SALLY: Ja, nee, eigentlich wollen wir wieder hoch.
>> MAX: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Aber ich komme nicht mehr hoch.
O Gott!
Woah!
Okay. Wer spült ab?
>> SARAH: Ach, okay. Gut.
>> JOSH: Dann machen wir noch einmal mit:
"Jetzt gibt's Zwetschgen..."
>> SARAH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja, genau.
>> SARAH: Dann müssen wir noch mal runter. Okay.
>> MAX: Warte. Ich sage wieder "gibt's", nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MAX: Ich sage einfach "gibt's".
Jetzt
>> MAX: gibt's
>> JOSH: Ich bin ja so...
Ich wollte einfach hochspringen.
>> MAX: Noch mal?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Noch mal.
>> JOSH: Cut!
>> MAX: Ich bin unten.
>> SALLY: Okay.